all right so an impressive win for the
Denver Nuggets without Nicole yic Aaron
Gordon Jamal
Murray man on the Clipper side of thing
there's two ways to break this down but
let's start with the Nuggets because
Reggie Jackson had this incredible game
where he was absolutely Unstoppable
Reggie Jackson put two halves together
and just continue to make play after
play I mean efficient on the night um
started off the first half and and went
into the locker room like hey they got a
slow him down but he continued in the
second half and when I tell you just
controlling the tempo of the game the
pace 35 points 13 assists initiating a
lot of the offense um being unselfish
when need be scoring when need be
defensively you know had a solid game I
mean I just think
that we always say it doesn't matter
who's out there they play professional
basketball too and you could tell the
Nuggets bench was ready to step into
this role with three of their key guys
three their starters out you know it's
it's this is so wild right because not
only was Reggie Jackson terrific but
Michael Porter Jr really was a nonf
factor three of 13 from the field but it
was the old man DeAndre Jordan hey
careful with the old best player 21 13
and five he had you know they had to
kind of dust him off a little bit Lube
up the joints and get him out there
caught four lobs in this game
yeah but you know at this stage of his
career he doesn't even go into a game
expecting to play much less to have to
perform at this level but he was
incredible as well that twom man punch
really kind of provided everything for
this nuggets team from an offensive
standpoint and then their defense they
held this Clippers team to 104 points
you know never allowed him to get out in
transition they only the Nuggets had 11
turnovers in in the game and while we
can talk about the Clippers this was
really as much about the Denver Nuggets
because if Reggie doesn't play that well
and DeAndre Jordan doesn't play that
well they don't win this game so they
had two veteran guys who've been main
cogs on good teams in the past so this
is not unfamiliar territory they just
haven't been asked to do that in their
roles now on this nuggets team until
tonight and I'm telling you they were
probably chopping at the right to go out
and play at this level and both of them
performed uh at an elite level I mean
they the Clippers were trying to double
Reggie down the stretch get the ball out
of his hand he was so effective at at
really just coordinating the entire
offense at staying in attack mode and he
got his rhythm early and just stayed in
it 15 of 19 from the field three or four
from three he shot better from the field
and from three he did free throw line
the only two or four the free throw line
but he did everything else impressive
impressive performance and I don't know
if Michael Malone will have a more
satisfying Victory all season to be able
to win with that roster you know having
your main cogs out on the road against a
team that was starting to play a little
bit better basketball this was
impressive yeah and DeAndre Jordan by
the way his first 20o game since March
of 2019 so it's been a while and again
like you said stepping up in that role
um that fourth quarter though Denver
outscoring La 36-6 it just seemed like
Denver was calm and cool and Collective
with Reggie Jackson leading the way
whereas anytime the Clippers had an
opportunity they look disjointed well
you let a team hang around hang around
hang around and I think regardless of
what you can say in the locker room
regardless what T can say sometimes when
you see three guys and especially when
joic is not in the lineup you see guys
like that not the lineup whether you
want to or not you let your guard down a
little bit and it seemed like the
Clippers in the first first half did not
come out and impose their will and
establish the game that they wanted to
play and so Denver you hang around you
hang around you let a guy get confident
like Reggie Jackson and then on the
other end you know you're not playing
solid defense and then on the other end
you have two of your guys in Harden as
well as PG that aren't shooting well
from the floor you know there was a play
that I think there's definitive plays
down the stretch that decide games where
Russell Brook comes down facilitates
probes gets the rack dishes it off to
Qui he misses a layup come down PG
passes up a three gets it back gets
fouled but passes up a good shot so then
you start second guessing yourself and
it just seemed like the Clippers were
kind of playing on their heels the whole
night because they let the Nuggets get
hot and get rolling and feel confident
yeah it it's not a light switch you know
you just can't turn it off and on and so
for me just watching couple things I
took away from the Clippers specific
ected there's never motion or movement
it's always like one guy gets in and he
tries to beat someone and then if it's
not there then he kicks it to someone
else and it's like there's almost like
no method to what they're doing right
now and and I think for tou a lot of
that is you know you have this
incredible talent and you you figure
okay I'm just going to let them try to
figure it out I think this is going to
be a scenario where he's going to have
to I think take a hold this thing from
an offensive standpoint and put in some
schemes that get the ball moving and get
bodies moving because it's just not flow
they just try to overwhelm you with
their talent they and at this level
that's just not going to work and at
this stage of all of their career
because they're all still really good
players great players but they're not
the dominant forces that they used to be
a few years ago and so they're not going
to overwhelm people they're not teams
aren't in awe of them and so they're
going to have to make some tweaks
offensively to get a little more Pace uh
get a little bit more movement
offensively to try to create easier
opportunities in the half court you know
to be honest with you I think this is a
team that needs to highlight the hockey
assists or the sacrificial cut because
you don't see that a lot with the
Clippers um the teams that play
extremely well you know and move the
ball automatically I gravitate towards
Golden State
um you had guys that were coming down
Swing Swing you had guys that were
coming down cutting to clear the lane so
that somebody else could get a corner
three and g is right you don't see that
a lot with the Clippers and you know
there is an offensive style to that but
there's also a time where you have to
come down and have ball and player
movement and you don't see that a lot on
the offensive end yeah a lot of figuring
out to do on that Clipper Squad no doubt
about that that's Denver's eight
straight win against the Los Angeles was
clipper